you want to choose from you intros we
can just do it
[Music]
yes hello everyone welcome back to
GameSpot it is Thanksgiving week here in
the United States of America and
honestly it's pretty slow here at
GameSpot but we were sent six bottles of
wine from ubisoft modeled and
characterized by the Assassin's Creed
characters that they are paired with
Lucy James you're the Assassin's Creed
expert in the office I am the resident
wine aficionado so we figured we team up
to rank and review the Assassin's Creed
games based on their wines or at least
the six that we have so let's get into
it she mentioned that I don't think so
I've never really so we'll be starting
off with Altair from Assassin's Creed
which came out in 2007 just read the
little description on the back this is a
lawar a valley IGP Cabernet Franc a la
deli displaying impressive finesse and
flavors of red currant and savory herbs
this red is the embodiment of Altea
the Cabernet Franc great trip the
Cabernet Franc grape tends to mature
quickly just as Altair became the
youngest to obtain the rank of Master
Assassin take a leap this dynamic wine
would be reformed in your tastes forever
did you take a wine classes oh yeah it's
like three credits my professor I got a
seat you haven't really massage these
off uh-huh this is a what wait yeah
that's a good here there we go
well yeah is that seventeen
oh that was the advance let it breathe a
little bit I don't know how long [ __ ]
that's a lot Oh little feline it's got
some peppery notes could see this
pairing well with uh some steak I mean
it's a red wine of course I'm sure but
like good steak okay Wow Cheers taste it
quite flat
it was very bland yeah yeah that was
known as a tasty that are gonna taste it
yeah I expected more pop ding doesn't
travel well either like it's just the
same note through I was expecting a
little flourish at the end there's no
yeah I actually felt more up front but
that would be good for it's a Monday
night
you are just sat it is a Monday night
but you're just sat in front of Netflix
and you don't want anything too too
overpowering it's tasteful its drinkable
mhm
so I'll tear not off to a good start
number two the Ezio Auditore da Firenze
see it's a 2015 Super Tuscan red wine
blend sourced from ETSU's birthplace of
Tuscany this red is charming and
charismatic like the renaissance hero
himself displaying flavours of cherry
and red plum on the palate it's an
enchanting Super Tuscan that will make
you believe in the enlightened
perfection that the assassins know
humans are capable of achieving that
description was going so well is enough
final half that sentence again if you're
like a really high-end restaurant you'll
see them they'll do it so to keep a
label facing you mm-hmm I'm good but I'm
not that good a surprising number of
people I went to school with and now
Emilio's which I discovered by the
meeting with Facebook the other day well
now you know another one thank you
say one
when this will be mine there's a hair in
that did we wash these out I did maybe
that was the wine I don't think it let's
deduct points for that okay okay swirl
Dustin see what kind of legs or work in
here no seriously that's the the you
know the legs are that's the lines that
it leaves when it goes down the glass
like I can't tell if he's bullshitting
no this is real it is sweeter
mm-hmm yeah it's a lot fruity it's not
as full-bodied as I thought it was gonna
be but I quite like it yeah I like
really dry tannic stuff this is good I
taste the cherry no no I'm out of it
hold on a second let me check Jesus
Christ what's the better Assassin's
Creed game based on these two Oh
Assassin's Creed 2 the wines the wine
wine never lies up next whoa you're
gonna like this one
we have corn up everyone's favorite
please proceed assassin 2016 horse
heaven hills Kevin a 70th
sometimes the most intriguing creations
are born from forging the old and the
new such as the case with this new world
take on Cabernet Sauvignon a namesake
for the complicated character of Connor
this is a wine that has something for
everyone
they're really trying to convince us
that that game was good vines are moist
are you excited for this one I'm excited
for this one because come on up Connors
my least favorite assassin yes so I'm
hoping that this wine can turn the tides
and an otherwise bland protagonist yeah
okay sanic dry I could smell that uh
leathery almost well I wouldn't expect
that with a Cabernet Sauvignon that's
kind of a nice little twist
I usually the leather is reserved for
like those Pinot Noirs you will find
that the more wines you taste the more
you crave that leathery mahogany kind of
taste
do I need an adult here again less
tannic that I would have thought as hmm
as my tongue got to know it shoot you
put your phone on vibrate oh sorry
who was it Oh No Wow
so I think Ezio still the full runner
mm-hmm I'm also Ezio Connor welfare but
I did like it it was fruity would
recommend would have what I have it with
nice a dose of Revelations Brotherhood
oh I was gonna say like a polonaise or
something can I interest you in these I
brought two pair well with the Cabernet
Sauvignon
you didn't bring them they're from my
lunch okay next up whoo we're going down
south with this one here we go our first
white of the evening and dare I say our
last I shall because I know what we're
doing the rest of the video just watch
these okay so
Eveline de grande mm-hmm I did German is
never study French oh that's a lot of
French words I got it okay
my French is abysmal as well 2017
ability on caught view on contour lay
it's a French wine just as aveline is
the ultimate social chameleon this
French white blend is infinitely
versatile definitely tackling various
food pairings and displaying different
characteristics each time the wine can
be buoyant or rich depending on the
match let it liberate your senses and
challenge all that you know so as you'll
notice as we go on there are no wines
for Edward Kenway A plus s creed 4 black
flag jacob and evie frye of assassin's
creed syndicate from 25th 50:15 yeah and
none from the reason Assassin's Creed
Odyssey C or not if you stick around
after our credits I have a little
surprise for all of you ok
we may get credit Smith okay Abilene
vigor on P the grand PP I don't know
whenever I'm in a restaurant and they
ask me to a wine like taste the wine I
was gonna do this just so also like
swirling it releases the bouquet which
can clue you in on to some of its like
an overture for the wine when you're
about to when you're at the beginning of
a show you know hits you in on the
themes of the the score that you might
be dealing with throughout the the show
but also it releases the taste it
because it couldn't that's why they say
let something breathe and that's why
wine glasses are shaped like this we
should be drinking this with a different
shaped wine glass because wine white
wines breed differently okay go
I'm like half really impressed and a
half wanting to give you a wedgie Bravo
Eveline I like it I like it because it's
not got that you know sometimes you have
a bad white wine and it has that awful
after taste like the sharp winners yeah
that's not I don't know it doesn't
really make me want to go in for a
second sit but this is going down very
well
mm-hmm
again not much of a a tail to it but I
like it is that well let's go to town
it comes sliding honestly you can call a
wine buoyant as we just learned I hope
you be impressed Irina Julie I really
like that so I'm just prized turn for me
at least
maybe you to assess degree deliberation
is the best Assassin's Creed yeah social
chameleon they call it enough that's
really good I like that's really good
yeah I would say number one what's up
current ranking so this and then Ezio
this then Ezio Venn Connor then oh yes
rob cam thank you can you slice me like
like no buggy game immersive game right
2017 politics connotates vine Nita istic
Ike its League of I guilt part of
Austria so that's a good I mean like
quality wine
Anita is too much quality one part of
Austria every played that game recently
for this thing I did on ps4 mm-hmm it's
still not great okay sorry okay just
kidding I'm kidding this is a I would
pair this with an Argentinian mistake
wait what Argentinean steaks while I
know they're from Argentina but what
else and what if they would they do it
wait wait what you guys not the smell
clue me in on your in this one is
actually probably ranked down the bottom
half for me okay by ik of SEMA
interesting thing about the wine
Tempranillo comes from temprano which
means early because these this grape
varietal ripens much earlier than others
oh very fruity oh very full-bodied very
not buoyant I'd say more like a like a
nice it's got some mass to it it's like
oh come on tell me you're still riffing
it's tannic but not in a good way oh I
like it's kind of flat for me there's
it's just fruit and nothing and I don't
like that there's no there's no journey
from beginning to end it's just
exposition and then I guess it's over
it's like it's like it's all up it's all
front-loaded and then the rest is just
boring
mmm bad is here no that'll be from
number 1 to 6 are no obvious yeah yeah
are you senator not for now the Rose
away victim yeah a PS Vita title is the
best Assassin's Creed followed closely
by a fan favorite Assassin's Creed -
that's not really surprised that's true
- Brotherhood on Revelations this is a
trilogy in a bottle a Tuscan blend if
you will yes Connor that's that's
surprising for me because I was not a
fan of Assassin's Creed 3 that it had
its moments
but I'm you know redemption for Connor
luckily they're remastering
as well about that South Korean unity
it was comes after that yeah that was
actually surprising as well didn't get
its fair shot because of all of the bugs
and everything the two experts weighed
in on it and they were like we should
give this a second chance here we go
they did in wine form I'll tear em in
law HUD from the Loire Valley Cabernet
Franc a sleeper hit I think it was a
good start to the whole thing but I
think it only went uphill from there for
the most part foundations and buy a cup
see WA surprising for the first time
ever you have disappointed me but there
are all some assassins missing there are
indeed what's one game that you were
kind of disappointed didn't get a wine
my personal favorites us in after Ezio
has to be able to light okay I have
something for that
what would Edward drink he's a pirate he
would drink rum you didn't even bother
to make like a fake label in Photoshop
or anything you weren't doing much today
but I figured we wouldn't be giving a
series it's fair shake unless we did our
due diligence and really took at least a
little sip of Black Flag I mean I love
wrong and just smelled it and that's bad
enough
I hate rum it's what
he hate them that's that's Sanskrit for
sucks this one's this is next not be
easier for me at least
oh it's from my your hometown so this is
a bottle of Beefeater which if you don't
know is gin from London I'm not so
actually this is I'm I'm excited to say
I liked it a lot Oh what does go well
it's better than that's up there
whereas in degree whereas syndicate go
[Music]
what okay so it's s Creed syndicate came
out this year it's very very know I
syndicate did not come on they see a
significant right right now I know that
was part of the joke so I have a
surprise liquid here that's kind of
related to Greece
here is Alexios and Cassandra it's a
bottle of olive oil and that's all I
could find
cuz so when I was a kid I always think
on holiday to the Greek part of Cyprus
so I knew that
luzo can booze you Oh gotcha
[Music]
definitely very viscous I would say good
look at the legs on that look at it and
lean still number one I would say sorry
the olive oil is getting to me oh there
you have it the absolutely definitive
and fun I mean you can't defy this I was
gonna say undefinable but we just
defined it so there you have it the
absolute and so there you have it the
definitive unquestionable Assassin's
Creed ranking thank you so much
everybody for stopping by and joining us
on this culinary cuisine based vintner
journey through the Assassin's Creed
series which itself is very historical
both in the context of the evolution of
games but also in the the lore itself
it's been a very very revealing journey
through from Altair down through his
ancestors and I'm very glad we took it
despite be sometimes awful aftertaste
that certain games left them my mouth